Publishing an app may not always proceed as planned.
That's why we created "Start Android with Google."
"Start Android" in trial start mode
Help select developers to use Google’s primary resources,
This way you can launch your app like an expert.
Start using Android,
You can access a large number of Google Play beta testers.
They will provide a wide audience
Intimate and honest feedback.
You will receive a design review by a Google expert.
Technical support and business consulting.
Take advantage of Google Play’s advanced developer tools
To iterate this feedback,
To build your best version of the app.
So if you are launching an app
And looking for guidance and support,
Please apply for "Start Android" immediately.